what needs to change is is the question
like I'll give you an example yesterday
Randi I was I was feeling super anxious
yesterday afternoon and I know I didn't
get a lot of sleep the night before
which I've been doing great in terms of
sleep recently but let the the night
before was just day was an anomaly and
and so I can probably link it to that
directly but what do you do in a
situation like that we're and I know you
work with a lot of people that who
experience anxiety when someone is
feeling anxious like I was yesterday
afternoon late to the point where I was
getting angry and and anger is not a
typical emotion that I I mean you know
me pretty well I you can't imagine me
like getting wanting to throw something
but I I felt that way and yeah I'm I'm
able to sort of repress that emotion we
were joking before the podcast started
like what was my memoir title on the
power of the power of repression that
Ryan was saying is like that the thing
that differentiates us from chimpanzees
the fact that we can repress really what
he was saying is you don't have to act
on some of these emotions and so
noticing it obviously yesterday but I
felt super anxious what do you what do
you talk to someone about if they're if
they're feeling anxious what are some
things to do yeah I mean I a few things
one thing when you when you get to the
anxious state it's almost you're almost
a little too far gone at that point yeah
so you have like some of your rituals or
things that you know you like to do that
calm me down like for me it is deep
breathing or like I travel I was
traveling here from South America
yesterday and it was a little stressful
and I just had that like almost a mantra
like you can relax
you can calm down just like kind of
talking to yourself in the which which
helps um but I think with anything that
comes up regularly like depression and
anxiety and things like that I like to
look at it as becoming friends with it
and so when it comes up being like hey
what are you doing here and how did you
get here and like do you want to hang
out okay cool
now you can go you know and it's instead
of being like
oh my gosh I'm feeling anxious not
feeling anxious that I'm feeling anxious
and why am i feeling angry now another
you're rid of this anxiety push it out
it's same thing with meditation where
yeah one of the mistakes that I often
get into with meditation is as I
meditate I'm like get rid of the
thoughts in my head push them out and
it's that's not the point it's about
watching the thoughts
so you're saying watch the anxiety watch
the the depression and and learn from it
it's like getting curious because the
body is constantly responding to its
surroundings and trying to give us
warning signs so like pain is a signal
from you know the brain to a part of the
body based on the information that it's
gotten so whether it is like a trauma or
injuries sitting a lot or an emotional
response or something your body when
when dysfunction comes up it's really
trying to tell you something
so when anxiety comes up or depression
comes up it's just like yeah and it's
like your shoulder hurting you know and
it's just like like something
something's up yeah exactly so it's nice
to just like as much as you can remember
that and be like okay this is what
happens sometimes why are you here do
your best to work through it but then
but then when you have calmed down a
little bit go back and look at maybe how
you got to that point like what was the
recipe that caused that to bubble up and
start to like course-correct a little
bit or adjust this here and there and
you can probably pinpoint why that ended
up happening you know for me I was able
to say hey I think it's linked directly
to sleep and I don't know Ryan he's been
struggling a lot with sleep recently and
and those mornings where you wake up and
you're you both have these like sleep
tracker rings and they just tell us how
bad we sleep right now I just yeah all
it tells me is that I'm gonna die a
really really tired human being Brian
this is an anxiety ring my through my
average sleep is like 65 dude it's so
much you shouldn't be alive right now
not like if I get there are a few times
we were out on tour where I would get a
65 and I feel dead you were the most
durable person I have ever met
it's he was eating a bowl of nails for
breakfast I came in here to pour milk on
it you know
just it's funny though because it makes
me sad because I feel like how would I
be if I was getting like a 90 sleep
score I would be unstoppable
yeah for me like I have to get above an
80 in order to function it's zero to 100
scale but like it heavily weighs deep
sleep REM sleep and especially length of
sleep and it seems to me like you you
really struggle with deep sleep but no
those mornings you wake up with with a
lack of deep sleep or whatever you feel
a noticeable difference whether it's
anger or frustration it's the easiest
things will frustrate you and it does
that with me too and I think yesterday
that was the problem yeah man if I get
up and I did not have a good night sleep
like I like I could be making coffee in
the ground spill a little bit and I want
to like throw my coffee mug through the
wall and then I had and I have to check
in with myself and be like Ryan buddy I
got this mr. Rogers voice that kind of
talks to me like it really is hey Ryan
you just didn't get good sleep it's not
that big of a deal relax taking a lot of
deep breaths like that it's so funny how
oxygen is anxieties enemy I feel like
cuz for me when I get to those really
anxious states like I do check-in and
kind of you know appreciate and I say
appreciate as in like just try to
understand why I'm at where I'm at the
opposite put the but deep breaths man
like really really it just helps me
totally relax dude if I could take ten
deep breaths it's not like this instant
magic cure mm-hmm but it does help me to
just take it down a notch the other
thing too I know
I noticed is that if I feel anxious I
will just eat a snack and I'm not even
hungry though I just feel anxious but
then I'll need a snack and then like
nine times out of ten like that's what
it is I was just hungry didn't even
watch sugar yeah that's right good sleep
I found for me when I'm anxious like
yesterday I will catch myself on not
breathing at all lay I'll just for I
know thirty seconds at a time I'm like
and then I realize like I looked at
Beck's yesterday at one point I said I'm
not breathing right now what's wrong and
I I spilt a glass of water last night
and like riders are going to bed and it
infuriated me and and but I had to do
the same thing I had to check in with
myself like hey it's just a glass of
water you can clean this up it's going
to be okay it's not a problem at all
this is not just fixable but when I pan
out for five minutes the problem is
gonna be over with yeah I think the
problem is like when we are in that
anxious state like maybe there is you
know whether it's sleep or maybe there's
you know something personal going on
it's like the little things bother us
because for me at least I feel like when
something little happens like if I spill
a glass of water when I'm a little bit
anxious it's like Jesus Christ I can't
even pour a glass of water right like
it's like this yeah well and this is
where self-care comes in because if you
have it a regular daily practice you
have some reserves for those stressful
times so if you're constantly depleted
and you're stressed out and then
something happens that it's like not
taking from anything so you don't have
really a lot to like cushion or comfort
yourself and so a lot of people you know
they when they feel good they don't
really they're just like I'm feeling
good I'm gonna just carry on with my
life but sometimes we also we try to
enhance the good yeah and we'll turn to
things that are like bad for us
whether it's like drugs alcohol partying
staying up late like whatever it is
right you know in a weird way yeah so it
is really important to keep just it's
like just continuing continually and
nourishing yourself so when you have a
moment or anxiety creeps in you have
something to pull from yes some reserves
there yeah
that way I like that
you